I really want to start with a sincere
thank you you've made me laugh a lot and
I just want to say thanks for that well
thank you for saying that I really
appreciate that so I'm just I want like
throwing a curve ball as my first
question if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before uh what
is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why oh my gosh you
know maybe here's a wild answer for you
maybe
um the SNL the singing sisters the
raccoon Christmas fun because it's got
animals it's got singing it's silly and
it's I love Christmas so it's got all
those elements and there's some glitter
it's sparkly all the things I like uh
speaking of SNL I am a fan I know a lot
of people watching this are going to
probably be SNL fans what do you think
they might actually be surprised to
learn about what goes on there behind
the scenes like before the show's going
to air or just like the behind the
scenes of the making of the show sure
well I think the hours always surprise
people and then I think um just the
amount of work and uh on from so many
different people you know when you get
to go see the show live to see the crews
on the floor building these sets in 30
seconds is is pretty remarkable and then
to know things get cut I mean really
it's
we care so much and it's always funny
looking back because every week is under
a microscope sort of and you'll be
dressed as a roll of toilet paper or
something and you're like I can't
believe my toilet paper scene didn't
it's all so dramatic for for being
sketch comedy it's probably also the
lack of sleep uh jumping into uh I think
that is a big part of it uh I really
enjoyed Le I really enjoyed Leo and what
I enjoyed a lot is that it has like M
it's a mess Mage movie but you never
feel like you're getting a message so
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of the film well I think that's
definitely because of the people
involved I mean I don't think I don't
think Adam Sandler would ever be
somebody who would make a a preachy
thing but he's got such a big heart and
so that comes out and what he does and
it's helps that it's really funny and
there's really fun song
so yes there's a message and it's and
it's got such a big heart but always he
makes sure it's he's always makes sure
things are funny talk a little bit about
the actual voice recording um what do
you think would surprise people about
like learning about like what it's like
actually doing the voice recording well
it is you are you're totally by yourself
and when we started I like the first
time I recorded I was actually in
Vancouver shooting shadon so I we we got
a uh like equipment to sort of build a
Sound Studio in this rental house where
I was filming so um I was like recording
myself in a closet with a zoom setup
working with these guys over Zoom so
it's really it's not until like the
second or third time that I even got to
really see the animation and see what
she looked like which was very cool
because then it's like some of the
choices that I made or that we recorded
then that would inform how they drew her
what what her face looked like making
that weird little sound that I or the
giggle I made last thing for you cuz I'm
basically out of time you never really
know how the film's going to turn out
when you're doing something animated so
what was your reaction to the film when
you finally saw it for the first time I
loved it and I got to see it fully in an
audience with a lot of kids there too
which was just made it even better and
getting to hear what grown-ups laughed
at what kids laughed at and then what we
all laughed at together was really was
really cool I hadn't I've never I've not
had that experience before and that I
got to stop I'm just going to say again
thank you for making me laugh I wish you
nothing but the
best thank you you
too